The moon has a side it never shows us.
Humans have flown by it to take pictures and
crashed a couple of probes into it, but we’ve
never landed a spacecraft on its surface to
get up close and personal with our satellite’s
hidden half.
Until now.
First though, some clarification.
Sometimes this side of the moon is referred
to as “the Dark Side of the Moon.”
That’s inaccurate.
The moon is tidally locked with the Earth,
meaning one side is always facing us, but
the side facing away from us still gets sunshine.
So the more correct term is the far side of
the moon, and Dark Side of the Moon is just
a killer Pink Floyd album.
China’s Chang’e-4 probe will be the first
spacecraft to poke and prod and study this
hidden side of the moon.
But why go there at all?
A big reason for this mission is, well, because
we can.
As the name implies, Chang’e-4 is not the
first of its kind.
The first Chang’e mission, named after the
goddess of the moon from Chinese mythology,
was an orbiter that launched in late 2007,
orbiting the moon for a year and four months
before it’s planned impact in march of 2009.
Chang’e-2 was built as a backup to Chang’e-1,
and launched in 2010.
It orbited the moon before setting off for
the Earth and Sun’s second Lagrange point,
and then continued on to fly by an asteroid
in 2012.
Busy little craft.
Chang’e-3 was China’s first lunar lander,
and it touched down in 2013.
Along with the stationary probe was a little
rover about three quarters the mass of the
Opportunity rover on Mars.
The rover was named Yutu, meaning “Jade
Rabbit.”
Going back to Chinese myth, a rabbit was the
goddess Chang’e’s only company out there.
Yutu set a record as the longest lived rover
on the moon.
It even discovered a new type of moon rock
that helped scientists better understand the
moon’s history of volcanism.
Which brings us to the present day.
Like Chang’e-2, Chang’e-4 was built as
a backup in case the Chang’e-3 mission failed.
But it didn’t, so why not go bigger and
bolder with the spare?
With an upgraded suite of instruments and
experiments, Chang’e-4’s mission became
to explore the far side of the moon.
The exact destination is near the south pole
inside an enormous crater, the largest crater
on the moon in fact.
The mineral composition there is different
than other parts of the moon, and may be from
the inside of the moon that were brought up
by an impact.
To study their makeup.
Chang’e-4 has spectrometers, along with
ground penetrating radar and cameras.
The craft will also study the effects of solar
wind on the lunar surface, and it’s brought
along plant seeds and silkworm eggs to see
if they can grow in the moon’s low gravity.
Finally, its place on the far side of the
moon makes for an ideal spot to test the feasibility
of radio astronomy from there, since the moon
blocks out noise and interference coming from
earth.
Of course if the moon is blocking radio signals,
that makes getting data back from the lander
and driving an expensive RC moon car a little
more challenging.
To solve that, the Chinese launched a satellite
in May of 2018 that is currently orbiting
Earth-Moon Lagrange point 2.
With the relay in place and Chang’e-4 touching
down, we can finally learn more about the
hidden side of our nearest celestial neighbor.
Like science in your day?
Well you should subscribe!
And although we’re sending a rover to the
moon, we actually have a complete map of the
surface.
Which is a lot more than we can say about
mapping our oceans.
But how close are we to a complete ocean map?
Check out our video here and make sure to
keep coming back to seeker.
Thanks for watching